Harlem Globetrotter bull Bullard usually
takes trick shots on the basketball
court but today you'll be taking a shot
from up here the sky coaster a
free-falling white-knuckle boardwalk
ride this video is epic this is one
awesome trick shot Bulls aiming to take
a shot while swinging 110 feet above New
Jersey's Wildwood boardwalk accelerating
to sixty miles an hour in under 4
seconds this must be the craziest trick
shot ever
that's gonna be a 60 pointer nothing but
net
it's awesome it's number one we caught
up with bull to find out why the
Globetrotter was picked for this insane
trickshot one of the craziest one on the
team I'm an athlete oh and I look good
on camera that's why cuz I knew you guys
would come in uh what yeah the
opportunity was we wanted to do
something cool only on the beach and now
we were down there and we were just
looking like um see up nothing right
there so it's the sky coaster so we said
you know this is gonna be a crazy trick
shot how does bull nailed this sky high
three-pointer bull was attached to a
crane that lifts up into the air then he
presses a release and he begins to fall
but he doesn't fall straight down he
falls like a pendulum a pendulum works
by converting the momentum you get to
Bradley and redirecting it along an arc
due to the constraint of being attached
to a rope at the bottom of the swing is
his maximum speed he's travelling at 60
miles per hour that's 96 kilometers an
hour this would be the worst time to try
and make the shot it's incredibly hard
to be accurate when you're moving
relative to the target ball chooses to
take a shot at that hoop when he's
actually at the highest point but it's
also when he's momentarily stationary so
it's almost like you standing on solid
ground
there's a split second where I'm not
moving that's that that was that split
second that I had to take a shot the
basket was about 30 to 40 yards out you
had to be calm and I had to be really
focused I just let go we got it
people on the ground jumping over now
but yeah you did it we did it Bo totally
deserves number one because it's awesome
it was amazing
you